talk about scottie pippen confirms he's
furious with michael jordan after the
last dance how dare how dare the goat
offend scotty
so scottie pippen confirms his furious
with michael jordan after the last dance
usa today's story pippin said it was
challenging for him to see jordan
constantly glorify while he and his
teammates were not given nearly enough
praise for their contributions to the
six title runs while pippin said he
wasn't surprised at the depiction and he
felt it would have been naive to expect
anything different being demand demeaned
once again was brutal because it was
insulting enough when it happened in
real time beyond the journal listing
integrity that vanished when the
producers gave jordan editorial control
of the final product pivot also felt
fiscally slighted as well to make things
worse michael received 10 million
dollars for his role in the dock while
many teammates and i didn't earn a dime
another reminder of the pecking order
from the old days for an entire season
we allowed cameras into the sanctity of
our locker rooms our practices our
hotels our holders our lives what do you
have to say about this with scotty
pippen look scotty
let's take a lesson here bro
back up know your role do you understand
that he is now one of the greatest duos
of all time not because he he was a top
50 player
mj's the goat
the goat i don't think there's any
question of that now he feels slighted
he's coming back he feels fiscally
slighted
scotty i know he's dealing with a lot
with his wife larsa he feels like he's
you were looking to maybe buy in his
house at one point we looked at his
house okay that's actually a nice house
the basketball court on the right side
yeah look
if i'm scotty
just stay in your lane bro you don't
want to make waves with mj this is not
the direction you want to go with the
the legacy of your career now he's
fighting with isaiah thomas you see why
isaiah thomas had to say about scotty
because scotty was talking trash about
isaiah about not making the dream team
isaiah says look i'll take it from mj
i'll take it from
you know hakeem or you know the greatest
of all time scotty know your role bro
yeah and this is just basically
overstepping you know you know what i'd
want to hear here's what i'd want to
hear if anybody has this and then we'll
go to the rest of them does anybody have
an argument to say that scotty's got a
point does anybody have an argument for
scotland i want to hear a little bit you
know i'm curious i have a unique
perspective because i was there for
every day of the last dance for those
three literally i was there every day i
was in the middle of everything you
watched every game yeah i was at every
practice i was in the i worked at nbc as
the sports anchor from 1995 to 1998. but
people don't know
was the guy with the white poofy afro
he doesn't want to tell who he really is
tom tell us every single second of the
last dance rodman's parties we hosted a
show with dennis rodman every sunday
night we could do a whole show on me
just giving you rodman stories now
scotty's brand is exactly like it was
back then it's bitterness and it all
stems from
money right it's all about money with
scottie pippen he knows he got screwed
over as a player he knows how great of a
player he was everybody knows how great
he was eight years on that first concert
seven years eighteen million dollars
time out though he didn't get screwed he
signed a badge well yes he did and he
knows it but here's the other thing with
scotty here's the other problem with him
he hasn't evolved into a second act
right so everybody else is an analyst is
an executive is a is just a personality
an owner of a team a coach steve kerr
everybody is somebody he's still sitting
in that rocking chair whining about the
old days and he's bitter the wife has
something to do with it remember back in
the day his nickname was no pippins
no tipping pippin there was always
something about him he always had a chip
on his shoulder that helped him become a
great player no tip and pimping
no i don't think michael had that
michael was generous you know the the
barclay interview with him and uh uh
oprah winfrey where barclays like how
cheap michael is you don't remember that
like okay but i think what he was
talking about is not paying back
gambling debts or something you know or
maybe not paying for a meal but scotty
had that reputation so look he is he's
not going to change because nothing from
his past is going to change he's not all
of a sudden going to make more money he
should he he controlled his own destiny
even with the last dance
that show would not have been the same
without him he should have said i want
some thing for participating and i
guarantee you one last thing this story
says michael jordan made 10 million for
the last dance he would make way more
than that all right with the success of
the last dance michael did not leave a
double 10 million to michael first of
all right he's got he just salty at this
point
i think that's what he's just like see
that in the documentary he's bitter and
it's all about money and you can kind of
understand that because you realize guys
right now make 18 million dollars a
month well my first story in the last
dance was the episode where basically he
refused to go into the game he wanted
the show
tony hit the shot the game winner and
and that's pippin's legacy as great of a
player as he was you can call him one of
the best duos the the the robin's uh
mj's batman he's still the guy
that was too salty to go into the game
let me ask you let me ask you a question
let me ask you a question here's a
question for you i dropped that thing if
you don't picking it up here's a
question for you question for you is the
following okay how many people knew uh
that michael and scotty won six
championships together how many people
everyone keep enough okay great fine
just follow me with you okay how many
people knew steve kerr and john paxton
hit some of the last you know
three-pointers or the shots that they
needed
everyone okay
how many millennials gen z's knew the
cuckoo story with pippin who didn't want
to go in zero that's the point and i
think that if
i think if they would have left that
story out this would have never happened
but it needed to be in there i think if
they left that story out scotty's not
like this this is the thing with scotty
though he's not necessarily wrong uh
luke longley came out and did a whole
thing about the last dance and how much
they left out and how it was all about
glorifying jordan nobody cared because
he's luke longley and horace grant was
also a guy that was like whoa was i an
afterthought i was i was one of the best
players in the nba on the first on the
first three i left for a max contract so
horus grant to me they made him like a
clown like that somehow you know robbed
and was one of my favorite players of
all time i have his jersey make fun of
me from wearing it around i love dennis
rodman but they acted like rodman came
in and like saved the franchise horus
grant was an amazing player so there
there was a narrative being formed
around the fact that like you know this
thing was falling apart and they had to
get the right pieces and it was jordan
as a leader i'll go get rodman from
vegas and stuff luke longley said the
reason robin was in vegas is he was sick
of jordan [ __ ] so that's why he's like
screw this but how many titles do those
guys win without michael it's so easy to
[ __ ] about it michael jordan don't get
me wrong but scotty pippen is getting
the this is the site i want i want to
hear this because the argument is so
one-sided with logic but i want to hear
this side to kind of hear it to you know
listen to luke lonely look like i saw
what the problem is but here's the thing
okay so here's the thing let's just say
say luke longley goes and does a
documentary let's go do a documentary
look longer how many people watch it a
lot in australia okay say
say scotty goes as a documentary how
many people watch it
that's the thing he's going to make a
lot of money off of this so you know i'd
watch it would you watch horseback
riding i watch it for his videos i
really would oh by the way i would watch
scottie pippen's documentary but am i
going to spend five weeks of every
sunday night from eight to ten at my
house sitting in the theater room
watching it together texting everybody
saying did you see what just happened
now something that you always talk about
pat is scottie pippen would be a good
thirty four thirty it's not gonna be a
five weeks or two episodes something
that you talk about is that mj has
reached saint status
you can't because not he's not even
close how often do you say that when you
reach saint status like rogan has
reached same status yeah dave chappelle
has reached out you can talk all the
trash you want about
you know lower them on the totem but the
thing is it's not even so much that that
he can't that you can't say anything
about jordan jordan played when he was
sick jordan played after his dad was
killed
scotty walked like bro we didn't for we
don't forget yeah then you walked away
from your team like we don't forget that
like you don't go in there crying
because at the end can you imagine
had he not done that how many
endorsements he would have got michael
jordan is worth 1.5 billion dollars and
it's not from the nba and scotty was
missing the big picture and he's still
doing it now sure because not even that
he did not negotiate in the last dance
to make any money ricky right but he's
always been horrible negotiation
without jordan
what did jordan win without scotty okay
so let's go there let's go there let's
actually go that's a good conversation
let's go there would jordan have one
without scotty he won when scotty had
walked out eventually found a way to
pivot because that's michael jordan by
the way pivot he's got a point couple
games game seven scotty was like i have
anxiety have this i have that so but the
question is this
let's say let's say scotty that one
season that he sits out let's say kraus
let's say those guys trade them let's
say they do
does jordan eventually win without
scotty
he never did how would we know
i'll say i'll say he wins at least one
without following it's not about one
guys it's not even a question it's not
even a question i say
jordan without scottie wins another
three or four i'm not saying six but i'm
saying three or four okay let's let's
face it if if phil
if shaq and kobe could have gotten along
and phil could have made it work and
carmelo never came to the lakers peyton
never came to the lakers those guys
never came to the lakers they kept the
squad with the two main guys with a
couple role plays around them rodman
type of players defensive type of
players if they kept it that way how
many championships would have the lakers
won
unlimited
quite a few of them right now we
obviously don't know the answer to the
question but here's the part this is
this is the angle i take so gerard think
about when you and i are speaking
off-camera okay and we talk about
branding vision story future right what
do you want to be that one conversation
we had two and a half years ago in the
conference room where we're writing all
this stuff out on the board you know
what i'm talking about right okay sounds
good who is that for scotty who's
sitting there with scotty a good
publicist saying hey scotty i just want
to have a conversation with you buddy
the route you're going you're going to
be the bitter player that is not going
to build a brand i'm just letting you
you can do this but i'm just telling you
let's re-branch guys let's have a
different at this conversation with a
couple other guys in the last few months
the market thinks you're a dick this is
not a good look for you if you want the
market to change you got to change your
approach you can't be pointing fingers
at everybody all the time scotty went
that route scotty could have taken a
route and said
my said my my
argument would have been scotty the more
you edify
jordan the more the market's gonna say
you're not a top fifty you're a top 25
the less the more you undermine jordan
the more you're top 100 because a big
part of that attitude is unattractive
it's just unattractive yeah being
gracious as you age is a bad bad look to
your point i would find out exactly who
did mike tyson's rebrand and i would pay
them everything marijuana mike tyson
went from you know having a tattoo and
threatening reporters on on air to
having a child's cartoon on adult swim
and you know being like a you know
america's crazy one what tyson has been
able to do is take a look at his past
indiscretions and all the mistakes he
made embrace them face the truth and say
and own up to it and say look i [ __ ] i
don't even know that guy anymore the
stories he says on podcast i know you've
interviewed him you've had moments with
him yeah he's so real at this point and
so inspiring that you can't help to to
love the guy who was probably he was the
baddest man on the planet
scotty needs to take a lesson for
michael yeah but it's got to be sincere
because that's the thing about tyson
it's legit he has that inside yeah but i
don't think scotty has it he's too
bitter he has to number one overcome
that bitterness for anything to change i
think that's what that's kind of saying
though somebody tells you somebody's got
to grab them in the room somebody has to
be like
because because the way it's going right
now it's going to get worse it's not
going to get better right nobody is
turned on by a bitter guy nobody is no
one's turned on by that by the way even
look at barclay look at barclay's resume
actually look at his resume
never won a championship
never want to change he is loved he
never and he calls out everybody and he
says his own [ __ ] he never ever won a
championship probably one of the most
loved beloved guys ever he'll never be
in the category of a champion right now
the most teflon person in america can
get away with saying anything okay but
by the way think about analytics by the
way when when when scotty talks and he
gives us an analytical side when he i
don't know which one it is tnt or not
tnt
he's on one of them when he does it i
sit there i'm like damn i didn't even
see that perspective and i'm not in the
world i felt like i went in the world so
scotty could be one of those guys right
the media and fans are not turned on by
bitterness there's one more point about
that era of the bulls and i think this
is part of the problem for scotty
there will never be anything like those
bulls ever there was never anything like
it you know with no social media and
they'll never be anything like it again
with michael i think scotty got caught
between thinking am i an icon or do i
have to get another job and i thought he
was living off the fumes of the bulls
aura for so long and he didn't know how
to monetize that so then he was stuck in
this little gray area and it stuck with
them for 23 years you know i was trying
to say that scotty pippen can't afford
gucci flip-flops i think
is what the bitterness is coming from
you know the fan base they love humility
and champions with humility become
legacy and i'm going to go to baseball
for the side of the table um because
there's something i've always always
admired and it's 1988 world series
everybody talks about the gibson home
run but who carried the team oral
horserizer he won the cy young that year
he broke down diesdale's scoreless
innings record at 59. pitched a shutout
in game four and pitched a shutout and
gave four shut down
shut the series off and all he has is
praise and admiration for kurt gibson
and that's how i got my ring and in
dodger land and he's a commentary with
the dodgers he his status is elevating
he didn't have a long enough career to
have hall of fame consideration but his
status is elevating because he's giving
praise to gibson he's giving praise to
lasorda and everybody looks at it you
know what he could say something
attractive
he could be pissed off and going down it
i won the cy young i broke
drysdale's record it was a 97 pitch
complete game that he threw in the world
series think about that by today's
standards 97 pitch complete game he
could be going down that and says damn
it why didn't i get the love
in a weird way this is this brings it
all back to like donald trump for me
it's like what made trump amazing he
edified it's great to be an american you
should be great i love being a part of
this we're winners let's get in together
and then he was bitter anybody says
anything bad about him i can see why
your husband left you you're ugly like
it's like he couldn't stop it's like you
can't just be like maybe scotty feels
this way pen pen and be like look man
you know what i don't know if the last
dance really told the whole story
there's some things you didn't learn i'm
going to put it in my doc love michael
love the things that we did together but
there's another side big picture rather
than like going for ted
instead of you know trying to win the
battle you know look at the war try to
win the war right now he's going after
yeah i didn't get this i didn't get this
if he looks at the big picture totally
and if someone sat him down in the room
and said look think about your legacy
think about what you want to be known as
not trying to win these
the key though i really think and you
hit the nail on the head as you age like
he's an icon he's this it's the people
like that you you start listening to
right it's the person that has to be
like all the time who can sit scottie
pippen down that he'll actually listen
to him be like scotty bro cut the [ __ ]
you know what it is somebody has to say
the following somebody has to say
look like like even with
kids or people you talk to you know hey
the other day dylan's like hey daddy am
i better than sam in jet ski no you're
not you're not he's way better than you
and jet ski i said well you're better
than when i was eight years old on jet
ski because i've never forgotten been on
jet ski until i was my third you know i
said you're better than me when i was
eight years old it's like okay i'm
better than you eight years old right
it's somebody has to say i don't know
bro hey
scotty there's no justice in iran
so anyway so somebody has to tell scotty
behind closed doors scotty i love you
you're amazing you and michael i'm just
telling you stop acting like you're
better than michael and fyi every time
you edify lebron to say he's better than
michael everybody knows what you're
doing everyone knows that's coming from
an insecure place stop it just like when
isaiah says lebron's better than michael
isaiah we all know you're pissed that
you didn't make it on the dream team
everyone knows michael's better than
lebron everyone knows michael's better
than scotty what are you doing it's not
even like that argument so scotty could
have taken a different ride listen 40
loss of power rule number one you know
what rule number one is never outshine
the master don't replace the boss for
the face of the team replace the boss
for master replace the boss for whatever
the mvp is you don't outshine jordan if
he doesn't outshine jordan he's gonna
get a million and one other
opportunities
one last thing
psychology less right
i mean the fact that he doesn't have a
supportive wife now i don't know
anything about their marriage for real
but i do know she's chasing headlines
and she's not probably sitting there
telling scotty how great he is and he's
been humiliated by her by some of her
actions so that doesn't help that
doesn't help matters either true i don't
yeah but by the way i mean that's that's
who you marry but at the same time
he's not the first person that had
accumulating stories with wives on the
personal life you still gotta you know
people can have a choice on what they're
to do that's what i want to say before
we move on let me let me just remind
everybody that's listening to this
20 super chat gets you in the giveaways
we have a playstation 5 we're going to
be giving away iphone signed books and a
couple other surprises we get to 10 000
people live by the third hour the last
super chat will give ten thousand
dollars away but you gotta share this
with others to get to ten thousand live
we'll give a ten thousand dollar super
chat away we got a surprise guest that's
gonna be coming here but go ahead you
were gonna say you're fine
i know we're just piling on scotty we're
sitting on scotty that
the wife thing is true she's definitely
embarrassing him and going after
headlines she's dating a guy malik
beasley in minnesota you know 20 years
her her senior he did lose his son
scottie pippen jr over the last six
months
and yeah that's just that's sad you know
so he's been going through some stuff
he's probably dealing with the major
mental issues anxiety
depression he's lashing out
someone does need to sit him down but he
is going through it bro and i hope you
guys love scott he loves totally now a
great point on what you just said right
there that's why adam what i go back to
is
sometimes we have a conversation and
it's a private conversation that's just
between you and i it's not the world's
issues it's you and i talking about it
right
those people that are around you that
are not afraid to tell you listen dude
chill out a little bit kick back a
little bit if you eliminate those people
out of your life
i'm sorry you're gonna have more
situations like this scotty needs to
bring some of those people in his life
to say
you know chill out a little bit so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you